this guy above Europe looking like a war
zone aircraft from 25 NATO countries are
playing out how to react to an attack
from the East military officials denied
the trails are aimed at sending a
message to Russia is this exercise is
not a signal directed to anyone it's a
signal to ourselves to Nato itself
because it's mostly NATO Nations
participating under German command a
signal that we can defend this country
and this Alliance
the exercise has been planned since 2018
after Russia annexed Crimea but
officials say the invasion of Ukraine
has made it even more urgent since a
creation of NATO after World War II no
exercise has seen so many foreign planes
and Personnel deployed in Germany that
is a big challenge for all the nations
coming to Germany as for example United
States as a country which is further
away had a lot of challenges to bring
all the aircraft all their material over
the Atlantic Ocean but as well the other
nations close by so the deployment is
yeah in the beginning exercise after
exercise the most important part of
course during the 10-day drill three
busy commercial flight zones will close
for several hours every day most likely
causing air traffic disruption and
delays for passengers NATO countries are
taken to the sky to flex their muscles
at a time when the war in Ukraine seems
to escalate while officials have
stressed that the hypothetical enemy in
this exercise is not Russia these
Maneuvers above Germany and further to
the east will send a message to Moscow
soon Dutch f-16s participating in the
drills could be sent to the war zone in
Ukraine in the next few weeks Ukrainian
Pilots will be trained to fly the
American-made fighter jets Air Force
personnel participating in the drill say
they are unfaced by the reality of the
war in Ukraine for me I believe that
it's a great opportunity for Unity
um even though we understand there are a
lot happening within the European
theaters the air Defender exercise has
nothing to do with what is happening in
the Ukraine currently we are focused on
just strengthening our Partnerships as
well as being good allies at the end of
the drills NATO countries hope to know
that in the case of an attack on one of
their members they can count on enough
air support from the others stepfather
Al Jazeera wunstorf Germany
and NATO members have poured billions of
dollars of Aid into Ukraine since the
War Began helping the country hold out
against larger armed forces from Russia
let's look at the numbers the U.S is by
far the largest contributor sending
weapons ammunition and military
equipment worth 46 billion dollars by
the end of February this year the UK is
the second biggest donor its assistance
amounts to seven billion dollars and
includes fighter jet training for
Ukrainian Pilots Germany's support
involves armored personnel carriers
drones and leopard two Battle Tanks A
package totaling 3.8 billion dollars to
date while Poland has sent equipment and
ammunition worth 2.6 billion dollars and
it also plays a vital role in logistical
efforts to deliver International
military aid to Ukraine
Jamie Shear is an associate fellow at
the British Think Tank Chatham House he
says NATO is focusing on air superiority
this has been planned since 2018 NATO's
done a lot of exercises uh using its
land forces and also Maritime exercises
one a large one took a place in the 40
just last week but the the air picture
has been if you like the missing piece
of the puzzle here many of the pilots
will be exercising in this air Defender
Europe exercise will be uh coming
together for the very first time there
are all kinds of different aircraft
Nature has to make sure that the command
control system the interoperability of
the aircraft will work well also the
integration with the air defense systems
like Patriot anti-air batteries on the
ground and also with missile defense so
it's very attack from the technical
point of view it's a complicated thing
uh air superiority is absolutely crucial
for the success of ground operations and
so NATO has to make sure that it has air
cover for all of the troops that it
would be putting into Europe any events
of a conflict with Russia the NATO has
made it clear in this exercise that the
aircraft will be operating in NATO
airspace only over NATO territory
there's no question of flying into
Ukraine there's no question of flying
over collini grad or coming closer to
Russia it's purely about Collective
defense